We decided to celebrate cakes this entire week
because you know, why not?
I mean, really, it's 2020, bring on the cakes!
And our next guest is a cake enthusiast,
host of Food Network's "Girl Meets Farm",
and award-winning blogger,
and author of "Molly on the Range".
And you can see my book is completely
annotated and folded over.
Please welcome, someone who I'm so freaking out to meet,
Molly Yeh, yay!
Hi Drew.
I am so freaking out to meet you.
Happy cake week.
This is the best week ever, officially.
Look at my cookbook.
Can you tell how ridiculously dog-eared it is?
Okay, so I saw last night on Instagram
that you made my ex-boyfriend's meatless balls
from that book, and let me tell you, Drew,
that just completely validated that entire relationship.
I have a few meatless ex-boyfriends too,
so I totally get it.
And I just think that reading your cookbook also,
you're such an incredible storyteller.
I've poured through your blog.
I love your writing so much.
And your whole life, and your husband, and your baby.
And it's cake week, so let's do this!
What cake are we making?
Okay, we are making my chocolate chili splatter cake,
which is so rich, and chocolatey, and moist.
It's really easy to make and it's so much fun to decorate.
All right, tell me what to do.
So, to start off, okay,
so I use my basic go-to chocolate cake here.
Which I love because you don't need a stand mixer
to make it, you just need two bowls and a whisk.
All the ingredients are easy to have on hand
at all times for cake emergencies.
The dry ingredients I always mix up first.
It's just flour, sugar, unsweetened cocoa powder,
your leavening agents, baking powder and baking soda.
Look how beautifully this is placed, Molly.
I really love this.
It's like the dry ingredients,
but they're like in a perfect, Nick, can you see that?
And does it smell,
can you smell the cocoa powder too?
I just love the smell
of making cake.
Certainly can.
And then I like to add a little bit of cayenne pepper
because chocolate and chili go really nicely together.
One of my favorite things that is in your book,
which I've never seen anywhere, is you have,
is it cayenne sprinkles?
Yeah, you can, okay.
Did you know that you can make your own sprinkles?
Now that it's cake week, you should try it.
It's so easy, it's just icing that you mix up.
Maybe we could do a digital piece
for how to make your own sprinkles.
Okay, what next?
Yes!
And then when you make your own sprinkles,
you can do different flavors.
Okay, next we have the wet ingredients.
I've got my eggs, oil, milk, and then some vanilla.
And you just whisk up to the wet ingredients,
add it to the dry ingredients, mix it up.
And now, here comes my little tip.
Once most of these ingredients are incorporated,
you add boiling water.
And the boiling water helps the cocoa powder
to incorporate and bloom so it becomes
its best version of itself when it hits the boiling water.
You could also use hot coffee.
But the reason that you add it at the end
is because you don't want the boiling water to cook the eggs
that were in the wet ingredient mixture.
So this gets mixed up.
And then you wanna be careful not to overmix it
because that could create a gummy cake,
and nobody wants that.
Once this batter is mixed, it goes into the cake pan.
I'm using two eight inch cake pans,
but you could also do a sheet cake, or cupcakes,
any shape you want.
Gets baked at 350 for about 28 minutes.
And then, this is the frosting.
It's just a basic American buttercream.
It's softened butter, powdered sugar, a little bit of milk.
Or instead of milk, you could also use booze,
depending on what mood you're in.
I love it!
Cayenne, coffee, booze, Molly.
You're not only the cutest, prettiest person,
you're also the coolest.
I love you, Drew.
I love you, Molly, so much.
You are the coolest, I love you!
Okay, so once you have your frosting and your cake,
you frost it to create this canvas.
And now we're just going to mix up our paints
and unleash our inner Jackson Pollock.
So all the paints are, are just powdered sugar,
and water, or milk, or any liquid.
Again, you can use a little booze in here too.
And then you mix it up with some food coloring.
You can use gel or liquid food coloring.
Can I tell you what Lisa and Ashley did here,
who set this up by the way, they did rainbow spatulas,
which I bet are, yup, they're Flour Shop, Amirah,
that match it.
Oh fun.
Oh I love Flour Shop.
I love Amirah.
She's gonna come on this week.
Ready.
Oh fun.
Okay, I'm going to be watching.
Okay now we're gonna splatter.
So you just start off with a little bit
and you just drizzle it all over.
I mean, it's not rocket science here.
Oh god, Molly.
We're having fun.
You got this.
Mine already looks crappy, but I, oh.
No it doesn't, it looks gorgeous.
Oh my god, this is one of the funnest things
I've ever done, are you kidding me?
Isn't it so fun?
Where has this been all my life?
And if you make a mess it tastes good.
Oh my god, Molly!
Oh my god.
I'm not kidding.
Isn't that fun?
I'm gonna go home and do this with my daughters tonight.
My daughters live, oh my god, oh my god!
I mean, this such a fun thing.
Wait, wait.
You can get the whole family involved.
(Drew screaming)
Hold on.
Yes, yes, yes!
Oh Molly!
(Molly laughing)
Yes!
That's it, I did it!
Go to our website for the full recipe.
And Molly, let's do everything together in life.
I'm so in love with you,
I think you're the coolest prettiest, neatest.
most wonderful thing.
I love you so much.
And everybody agrees because everybody loves you.
So please let's do more.
Go to the DrewBarrymoreShow.com
for the full recipe.
Thank you, Drew.
Molly, yes!
(upbeat music)